على الشاشه الان في تبادل مكثف كما يبدو
للقصف رشقه صواريخ جديده من المقاومه في
اتجاه العمق الاسرائيليه كانت رشقه
الصواريخ التي اطلقت قبل نحو عشر دقائق من
الان قد سقطت بعضها داخل
عسقلان وكان مراسلنا قد قال ان القبه
الحديدي اعترضت ثلاثه منها فقط وها هي
رشقه صواريخ جديده تطلق خلال هذه اللحظات
من قطاع غزه فصائل المقاومه اذا تطلق
صواريخ ودفعت صواريخ جديده من قطاع غزه في
اتجاه اسرائيل
في تبادل على ما يبدو للقصف بعد استهداف
الطيران الاسرائيلي بغاراته مواقع السكنيه
ومنازل منذ فجر هذا اليوم وكثفت من وتيره
هذا الاستهداف في الساعه الاخيره باستهداف
منازل في حي الزي وفي اطراف بيت لاهيه
كذلك عسقلان نشاهدها في الجانب الايمن من
الصوره
وهي تستنفر مع اطلاق المقاومه برشقه
صواريخ ودفعه صواريخ جديده وسيارات
الاسعاف كما نسمعها الى هذه المواقع ربما
التي تسقط فيها هذه الصواريخ
توقعا وتحسبا بسقوط اصابات
هناك في الوقت ذاته غزه وسماء غزه
نشاهد من خلالها هذه الرشقه الجديده من
الصواريخ والدخان ايضا في نفس الوقت الذي
ينبعث من المواقع التي يستهدفها الطيران
الاسرائيلي بالقصف داخل هذه الاحياء
السكنيه وفي بعض الاحيان اراضي زراعيه
فارغه